even by the standards of other famous
violent anomalies
scp-106 better known as the old man
is a complete monster consider this
scp-096 the shy guy is a mindless beast
that kills out of pure
instinct when people see its face
scp-049 the plague doctor kills by
accident with his deadly touch while
trying to help
even as cp 682 seems to kill because the
burning hatred for all life that resides
inside it
is impossible to suppress but scp-106
doesn't kill out of hatred
he kills out of love and what he loves
more than anything else is inflicting
pain misery and terror just for the fun
of it
in case you haven't seen our video on
the subject scp-106 is an invincible
sadistic old man
whose anomalous abilities allow him to
walk through solid surfaces
as a result he's incredibly hard to
contain making him one of the scarier
ketter class anomalies in scp
foundation containment and it's almost
impossible to escape
if you end up on his hit list but his
scariest ability of all
is dragging people into his pocket
dimension a private hell where he
controls both space
and time and can do awful things to his
captured victims to his heart's content
scp-106 is downright evil
and he couldn't be happier about it you
might assume that there are no hidden
depths to be plumbed when it comes to
the straightforwardly violent monster
but certain scp foundation discoveries
about the infamous old man may surprise
you
meet scp-978 the desire camera
this anomalous polaroid camera has the
remarkable ability to reveal the deepest
desire of its subject
and the foundation tested the camera on
several employees and anomalies
including scp-106
now you might have expected scp-106's
greatest desire to be causing more pain
his favorite activity but the
researchers were shocked to find out
that wasn't the case at all
the actual result according to test logs
was quote
scp-106 roaming a wheat field appears to
be
approaching an old farmhouse while a
woman appearing to be in her mid-60s
welcomes 106.
it turns out that even a creature of
pure malice like scp-106
may have some hidden secrets after all a
prospect that greatly intrigued
foundation researchers
while an obscene amount of work had gone
into containing the old man
and subverting his powerful anomalous
abilities comparatively little work had
gone into his origins
and while the foundation actually
started digging they were surprised to
find that the rabbit hole was far
far deeper than they'd ever imagined
much like the joker
the old man's origin story is multiple
choice
out of the reams of research into
scp-106's origin
we've narrowed it down to the three most
plausible possibilities for how a
creature like the old man could come to
exist
the divergent species theory the
scranton theory
and the corporal lawrence theory and
today we're going to explore all of them
first though let's look at the divergent
species theory
the main basis for this theory is
information gleaned from a tale known as
once but not
now this tale is seen as a collection of
memories from the atrophied mind of the
old man
detailing his origins thousands of years
prior
it's worth remembering that a lot of
these memories are of course
highly subjective and interpretive if
they are to be taken as the authentic
memories of the old man
then it is also important to note that
as a deranged compulsive sadist
details of his memories are possibly
unreliable
that being said according to the reports
contained within once but not
now the old man was once a member of a
hominoid family similar to that of
humans
but displaying the anomalous powers
we've come to expect from scp-106
enhanced strength corrosive mucus and
the ability to pass through solid
objects in the documents it is implied
that the primary source of prey for the
old man's species was actually
neanderthals
they had basic tribal cultures that
allowed them to organize hunting parties
for the purpose of bringing
food back to their camps they even had a
semblance of socially enforced laws
leaving members of their tribe to starve
after they committed murder against
their own species
if things had played out differently
this species may have stuck around
perhaps even surpassing humanity and
becoming the dominant species on earth
an entire thriving culture of scp-106
however as time passed the neanderthals
were eventually hounded to extinction
this destroyed the primary food source
for scp-106's species
which if you even have a basic
familiarity with evolutionary biology
never bodes well for a species as the
old man's species turned its attention
to humanity
it found they weren't nearly as easy to
prey upon as a result their species
slowly fell into decline
and eventually slipped into near
extinction the old man
most likely the last of his kind went
into a state of hibernation within a
tree
he remained in the tree for what may
have been thousands of years before
eventually climbing out into a world
that had long since forgotten
anything like him had ever existed the
old man woke up into a strange new world
filled with alien structures and garish
lights he wandered
confused and hungry haunted by the
knowledge that he was the last one
left of his kind he wandered around the
new world until he found what he
described as a nest
likely just a normal human home he
became distressed by the structures and
lights around him
until finally happening upon a food
source that he hungrily
ate this food source turned out to be a
human
infant not long after that he was
apprehended by figures described as the
men in white coats
who are likely to be agents of the scp
foundation he was contained not long
after that
these days his only motivating factor is
the search for pain and anguish
the only things that can give this very
very old man
any semblance of feelings anymore of
course this is actually the least
popular of the three theories
but it does pose a rather disturbing
question if ever there was a whole
species of scp-106
is it really possible that our species
would be able to outlast them
the second most popular theory was that
scp-106 was not only once human
but an extremely important foundation
researcher
namely dr robert scranton if that name
sounds familiar to you
it may be because you've heard of the
famous scranton reality anchors
these devices inspired by scranton have
been the foundation's greatest tools in
combating the anomalous effects of
reality warpers
and if the scranton theory about the
origin of 106 is to be believed
it's darkly ironic that it would be a
reality warping anomaly that would bring
dr scranton to his
unfortunate end the horrors began on
january 2nd
in the year 2000 when dr scranton and
his wife dr anna lang were testing a new
technology
the lang scranton stabilizer this was
the technology that would lay the
groundwork for the reality anchors that
would later be created in scranton's
name
however the stabilizer was ironically
anything but stable
and caused what is known as a momentary
class c broken entry wormhole
scranton was sucked into the wormhole
and transported to a pocket dimension
known as scp-3001
or the red reality many people assumed
scranton was dead
but the reality was far more horrific
scp-3001 which the still-living scranton
and the control pad of the stabilizer
were sucked into was a kind of empty
infinitely extending void the laws of
reality did not apply in the darkened
void of 3001
there was no space no light no passage
of time
it was the absence of all existence
except for scranton who was the one
speck of existence trapped inside as
whatever passed for time went on
scranton could only speak into a small
audio recorder embedded in the console
it became his only company the only
thing anchoring him to some semblance of
sanity
but of course that couldn't last forever
as he came to terms with the reality of
his situation
dr scranton became overtaken by fear and
then despair
he started to lose hope that he would
ever exit the pocket dimension of
scp-3001
and his coherent speech became terrified
disconnected ramblings as his mind
fell apart he tried to end his life 184
times while trapped there
but it never worked he took the damage
of each attempt
slowly becoming unrecognizable but there
was
no death to grant him escape from
scp-3001
as time went on the very state of
reality within the red reality began to
decay
matter started to become antimatter and
robert scranton felt himself coming
apart at the seams and floating into
nothingness
he was still conscious and very much
aware of his personality
perhaps even his very soul fractured and
drifted away
with his body in total he spent almost
six years inside the broken pocket
dimension
though this probably felt like an
eternity to him eventually even the
console vanished from the red reality
and returned back to our own leaving
whatever was left of robert scranton
truly alone those who loved him prefer
to believe that he's now as close to
debt as possible within scp-3001
but people who believe in the scranton
theory have different ideas
dr robert scranton or rather whatever he
became
was headstrong he wanted to escape the
red reality at any cost so he could be
reunited with his wife
dr anna lang through sheer force of
willpower
dr scranton pulled his disparate matter
back together
but it didn't come back in the way it
used to be there was something
wrong terribly wrong he was now
something less than human
scp-106 scranton
a man who'd spent his life developing
technology to keep reality consistent
was about to build his own reality he
would build destroy and rebuild again
and again he would create a perfect
reality for him and his beloved anna
which would later become his trademark
pocket dimension
but when anna saw the monster he'd
become she was horrified by him
his very touch destroyed her his
corrosive mucus
melting her away all was left was the
monster he'd become
the old man scp-106
of course there's one more theory about
the origin of scp-106
if you've ever heard the wall walking
monster referred to as uncle larry
this next story is why in fact it's the
most widely believed of all the scp-106
origin theories
the corporal lawrence theory so who is
corporal lawrence
we actually know very little about the
man aside from the fact he was a
military officer during world war
one our knowledge of him comes from
first-hand accounts of the soldiers
serving under him in the trenches
the corporal was described as a plain
aloof and vacant man
with a tendency to stare many of the
soldiers disliked him on account of his
incredibly flat personality
but perhaps even more so because
lawrence always seemed to be followed
around by the smell of rot
strange incidents also seemed to follow
him around
like soldiers in his barracks seeing
greater numbers of sicknesses like
trench foot
it was almost as if he was cursed and
perhaps
he was one fateful day lawrence and his
men
needed to raid an enemy trench they
infiltrated the trench and found that
everyone there
was dead and covered in a corrosive
black slime
worse still corporal lawrence discovered
a strange black hole in the trench
filled with the same black substance he
then collapsed into this hole
before climbing out clearly shaken by
the experience
after that everything went downhill
corporal lawrence appeared to completely
change his personality
becoming a perpetually grinning
eccentric with a head full of strangely
morbid
and sadistic thoughts at a certain point
his body seemed to reproduce the same
corrosive mucus he fell into causing
pain and sickness to his fellow soldiers
wherever he went
in the end after the horrific deaths of
some of the soldiers working under him
corporal lawrence and his men were
apprehended and interred at a military
hospital
not long after though he disappeared
along with the rest of his men
the only trace that remained was on the
former corporal lawrence's hospital bed
traces of the corrosive black mucus and
a ring
of human teeth pulled from the heads of
every single person on the ward
the next time he was seen corporal
lawrence truly was
no more only scp-106
remained and in his own sick little way
he'd never been happier and there you
have it
the three most popular theories into the
origin of scp-100
which if any do you think is the most
likely theory or do you have one of your
own
let us know down in the comments and
remember
keep an eye on the walls you never know
when the old man will drop in
for a visit now check out scp-106 the
old man escape
and scp-3001 red reality for a deeper
exploration into some of the topics and
concepts discussed in this video